so at this point i i think i have to say
something about the situation with
g-lane maxwell in particular because
this came up at donald trump's tuesday
coronavirus press briefing
and trump again was just caught in
another
apparent lie to the point where
i'm increasingly convinced that trump is
scared of what g-lane maxwell may reveal
anthony scaramucci believes that that's
exactly what's going on and so we're
going to go through it so just to reset
jeffrey epstein was arrested and charged
with multiple counts of sex trafficking
and assaulting young girls
this this video will now be demonetized
because i mentioned his name
unfortunately but we've got to talk
about this
this has been known for a long time
there's documentaries now about jeffrey
epstein it's been widely explored
documented he was ultimately
found dead in his jail cell of a
reported suicide
his girlfriend maybe ex-girlfriend
whatever
alleged groomer and trafficker of women
and girls
jilane maxwell who was out of the public
eye for some time
but has since been arrested a few weeks
ago
now there are widespread pictures from
the last 20 plus years
uh and videos of donald trump together
with
jeffrey epstein and elaine maxwell
including with melania trump without
melania trump over the years
there's video we once looked at of trump
and epstein at a party i believe it was
in the late 90s
trump and epstein together sort of
watching and discussing different young
women who were dancing in front of them
might have been the early 2000s
the point is widespread connections
between trump and epstein now donald
trump was asked about maxwell
on tuesday and trump wished her well
which is a really weird thing to say
about an alleged sex trafficker given
the number of alleged victims
but trump also mentioned something about
prince andrew
uh which you may find interesting so
let's take a look at that clip
just lane maxwell is in prison and a lot
of people want to know
if she's going to turn in powerful
people and i know you've talked in the
past about prince andrew
and uh you've criticized bill clinton's
behavior i'm wondering uh
do you feel that she's going to turn in
powerful men how do you see that working
out
i don't know i haven't really been
following it too much i just wish her
well frankly
i've met her numerous times over the
years especially since i lived in palm
beach and
i guess they lived in palm beach but i
wish her well
whatever it is i don't know the
situation with prince andrew
just don't know not aware of it so a lot
of people are focusing on trump saying
he wishes her well
arguably a wild thing to say given that
jilane maxwell is accused of grooming
and trafficking in young girls and has
left so many alleged victims in her wake
but the thing about and we're going to
talk about wishing her well in a moment
but the thing about prince andrew is
particularly interesting because once
again
trump claims total ignorance prince
andrew and epstein i don't know anything
about that
but we have video check out this video
from february
of 2015. this is when donald trump was
getting ready to run for president in
this clip
he says he's about 80 percent certain
he's going to run for president
and it sure seemed like trump knew a lot
about jeffrey epstein
and prince andrew in this clip take a
look you raised the question of jeffrey
epstein in your remarks about
in the q and a i think he's got a
problem i don't think the problem will
be i i don't know
but that island was uh really a cesspool
there's no question about it just ask
prince andrew he'll tell you about it uh
the island was an absolute cesspool
so friends are friends and he's been
there for many times well i can't say
friends but i know you're friendly you
know them
they play at my clubs a lot i have clubs
and everybody likes to play are you
saying
trump knows about the island and he says
prince
andrew specifically is the guy you want
to talk to
and he even kind of gives a weird kind
of knowing look to one of the
people sitting at that desk on camera
says prince andrew
can tell you about it so clearly in 2015
trump
did think and know about a connection
between epstein
and prince andrew so there's a couple
possibilities here and of course none of
them are good
uh one is trump is lying now trump lies
all the time this is what a lot of
people suspect
and the idea is trump has been
intimately involved with jeffrey epstein
and he knows all about prince andrew and
now he's lying and saying i don't know
anything about prince andrew but
remember
there's a 13 year old girl then 13 year
old girl
who at one point accused trump and
epstein of raping her in epstein's
manhattan condo that suit was since
dropped the other possibility
is again one of trump's cognitive
decline and you might have noticed that
in the 2015 clip i played for you trump
is obviously more articulate more
together
than he is now it's possible trump has
just lost
all memory and he has no recollection of
knowing about the epstein-prince andrew
connection
there have been allegations uh that say
trump regularly forgets things that
happened five days ago
forgets things all the time so either
trump is a liar
and he knows everything that there is to
know or much of what there is to know
about prince andrew and epstein
or he's lost his memory neither inspires
a lot of confidence now i want to get to
one other component of this
and that's what i'm going to talk about
next and that's the idea
that when trump says i wish her well
about jilane maxwell you hear that i
hear that it sounds weird why would he
wish
well to an alleged child sex trafficker
anthony scaramucci says that's code from
trump
to jilane maxwell to shut up and not say
a word about donald trump so let's talk
about that next
so the second part of the trump g-lane
maxwell story
is about what trump meant by i wish her
well now i already laid out for you
how on tuesday at donald trump's
coronavirus press briefing he was asked
about the arrest of jilane maxwell
uh the alleged groomer and trafficker of
girls for jeffrey epstein trump
bizarrely wished her well
and then said he doesn't know anything
about the connection between prince
andrew and jeffrey epstein
in the last segment we focused on
showing you in 2015
trump certainly knew about the
connection between prince andrew and
jeffrey epstein
let's now talk about uh i wish her well
take a look at this clip
just lane maxwell is in prison and a lot
of people want to know
if she's going to turn in powerful
people and i know you've talked in the
past about prince andrew
and uh you've criticized bill clinton's
behavior i'm wondering
do you feel that she's going to turn in
powerful men how do you see that working
out
i don't know i haven't really been
following it too much i just wish her
well frankly
i've met her numerous times over the
years especially since i lived in palm
beach and
i guess they lived in palm beach uh but
i wish her well
whatever it is uh i don't know the
situation with prince andrew
just don't know not aware of it now a
lot of people wrote to me saying
isn't it really weird that donald trump
asked about someone accused of horrible
crimes right
serial sex trafficking and grooming of
young women
and girls wishing her well that's weird
well of course it's weird
but donald trump is a weird guy he has a
different moral code than many of us
have
but there's a different perspective from
donald trump's former aide and very
brief white house communications
director anthony scaramucci who tweeted
about this
and scaramucci says trump is wishing her
well
not to wish her well it's code for her
not to talk
in other words don't cooperate don't
tell investigators what you know
about trump's activities possible
activities with jeffrey epstein
and scaramucci tweeted in the morning
earlier this week
quote she has the goods on him he is
signaling
please don't talk now of course it's
speculative but also of course if indeed
there's some connection that involves
donald trump and jeffrey epstein
there's no shortage of such allegations
donald trump has shown that he
is very much willing to reward people
who stay quiet
with either pardons or commuting their
sentences if you believe that trump
wishing her well
is a signal that she should stay quiet
there's really an implicit
threat there sort of like a mafia boss
suggesting that the guy who got arrested
hopefully is going to have good luck
right which means don't say a word
donald trump has used similar language
to other associates who have been
indicted michael flynn
roger stone paul manafort he's talked
about wishing them good luck
wishing them the best i hope for the
best for them so
there's a degree of speculation here on
the other hand you could say
of course that's what trump is doing and
it's completely obvious like there are
on the one hand there's people saying
this is sort of speculative
on the other hand there's people saying
clearly this is what trump is doing and
that's exactly what he's signaling to
her by saying i wish her well
now to go back to the beginning and the
sort of bizarre nature
of trump wishing well to a serial
accused
child sex trafficker just imagine what
would have happened if barack obama was
asked about someone
who had been accused of supplying
underage girls for people to sexually
assault and obama had said i wish them
well
think just for a second about what fox
news and all right wing media would have
done
for days if barack obama had done that
and you remember you know this myth of
the liberal media
uh just instantly crumbles before our
very eyes so in terms of
you know do i expect we're going to get
public news of any kind of allegation
from jilane maxwell about donald trump
before the election i really don't
there is a contingent that believes the
timing of this g
elaine maxwell thing is exactly so that
in mid-september late september early
october
there's just blockbuster allegations
made about donald trump and his
connection to jeffrey epstein
part of why i mean listen i don't know
if there that there is such a plan
i actually don't know that it would make
a difference at this point
trump was accused before being elected
president by 16
20 women i mean subsequently in books
that came out that number went to 30 40
something women who have accused trump
of different degrees of
sexual assault up to and including rape
and
trump's approval and his polling started
to suffer
when he failed on coronavirus when he
failed on the economic response to
coronavirus
when he responded to protests against
police brutality by threatening to
and actually sending in federal troops
so not only am i not sitting around
waiting for that to happen in terms of
g-lane maxwell
i don't even know that it would make
much of a difference i think that the
real issues continue to be
the ones that people tell us they are if
you look at recent polling the three
issues hurting trump are
virus response economic response
and response to the george floyd protest
slash race relations
i don't even know that this is really
what we need and more allegations from
jilane maxwell if she has them to make
she should make them and they should be
reported on
but waiting for that as what's going to
knock trump out of
office his supporters have shown they
don't care about that and i think that
that's the approach that we should have
if you disagree with me let me know i'm
on twitter at deepakman also remember
that you can get the daily every single
weekday monday through friday
daily audio podcast for free
on any podcast app that you prefer
itunes beautiful spotify available
google play podcasts have added hoss the
daily audio podcast typically released
at 3 p.m eastern every day we'll take a
quick break and be back after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are
lawrence sparrow
and leslie kaluza lawrence and leslie
thank you for your support and also a
big thank you
to anthony petramala who has been a
member for five years
almost almost five years and is today's
long-time
sustaining member of the day grab a
membership don't be bashful
at joinpacman.com coupon code 2020 now
this is
this coupon code is so big red state
governors hate it
um 2020 now saves you 66
off of membership let's go to the phones
at 617-830-4750 let's see if it's a good
phone's day
or a bad phone's day zero forty
617-830-47
fifty starting with our caller from the
five one six area code who's calling
today from five one six
hey is that me yeah who's this hey i'm
nick
from new york nick from new york what's
going on my friend
so i would like to know what is the plan
to stop trump from suppressing the vote
in november
i wish i knew i mean listen
um so there's a couple different things
going on here and
it's like you've got the paramilitaries
in portland and soon likely to be other
cities
possibly they will remain to intimidate
into november
you've got trump trying to prevent vote
by mail which is really just expanding
absentee ballots
you've got you know all of the players
that want to interfere in the election
still plan to you know russia possibly
china et cetera
i think the plan has to be we overwhelm
the vote by so much that the
interference doesn't matter i mean i
hate to say
it but i don't know what the plan is
nick
that's a great idea though i mean i mean
i hope
it works i hope that we do get this
president out of office because he's so
incompetent
yeah are you what state uh so do you
vote in new york
i'm actually too young to vote i'm 17.
oh my god
yeah that's okay unfortunately
if you could vote though you would not
vote for trump it sounds like i would
totally vote for biden got it okay and
so are you um
are you between high school and college
right now are you about to be a senior
i'm about to be a senior and what's are
you going back for in person or is it
virtual classes i have no idea
but you still don't even know yeah i
don't know yet
what would you prefer well i would
i mean i'm okay with either one
obviously i'd rather go in person
you would say and you'd wet what you'd
wear a mask you'd be okay with it
yeah yeah you do your parents have
strong feelings one way or the other
uh what what you say do your parents
have a strong feeling about whether they
want you
physically in school i don't know i
would have to ask them
oh all right all right nick very good
glad you're paying attention to the
voter suppression it's going to be a big
deal
i appreciate the call thank you so much
for taking it
all right take care nick from new york
got right to the question i love it
let's go to area code 678
who's calling today from 678.
hi david this is jp from marietta
georgia how are you jp how are things in
georgia i'm worried about you guys
um that's actually what i was calling
about i didn't have really a particular
question besides
just for your comment on the state of
things yeah i'm in the suburbs
outside of atlanta and you know we
have got tons of cases you know every
day in georgia
and i work in a music shop and i'm back
in the store i mean there's no any kind
of math mandate
or anything even for the employees
um not for the customers for anything
yeah
it's uh it is just ridiculous i'm
restringing people's guitars that
they're
you know bringing in and there's no way
really to sterilize them because
they're instruments and you can't put
disinfectant on them right through in
the wood
but and i had a funny thing i even
restrung a guitar
signed by paul ryan the other day
fairly dramatic imagine having a guitar
and wanting paul ryan to sign it you
know that that's crazy
it had a romney ryan sticker on it so i
think it was part of a promotional
like giveaway or raffle or something
like that so
it's i'm hearing that you're you're
feeling unsafe at work essentially like
you're totally unprotected people are
coming in they're handing instruments
back and
back and forth you're not wearing a mask
they're not wearing masks
right i mean well i i do wear a mask
every day oh you do okay
you know i've got sense i absolutely
it's just not required
yeah um so i have more conservative
bosses and
we're even back to doing like our bread
and butter is
lessons in person lessons and we've been
doing private lessons
in the store for a while as well myself
included
wow and now was the was the store
at one point closed when things were
more shut down
uh yeah we shut down uh from january
to march or they're about and
you know once once georgia you know
opened back up we
we came back in um you know
full force but kept our lessons online
for a few months
yeah starting in june um you know
completely ignoring all the numbers
starting in june we just decided
to let people start coming back in for
in-person lessons
and do the owners or your boss or
whoever i don't know what the structure
is do they even
talk about preventing the spread of the
virus or is it just like we're open for
business that's it
um we we have bought air purifiers
and uh we've got um you know stations
with um with hand sanitizer um and we've
got
cute little signs that they say two
guitars apart but other than that
uh not really wow well i mean that's
something i don't know
and let me ask you this i have a couple
friends down in georgia but i've not
asked them about this
in general like when you go to the
grocery store when people are out
is there increasingly the atmosphere
that things are just
normal or are people overall exhibiting
any kind of caution
um it's really hard to say i mean
it's really split just like you know a
good bit of uh you know everybody is
with you know the people saying i'm not
gonna be a sheep
yeah and you know masks are are you know
you know make you not a man and yeah you
know the other half of people
uh seem like they're taking it seriously
but and the school system
seemed to be having a problem with this
as well cobb county where i
am um that they were going to come back
in full force and then people
got mad and then they said they're going
to all virtual and now people are mad at
that
so i i don't know what they're going to
end up doing well listen
i don't envy you that sounds very very
tough and the georgia numbers are not
looking good
all we can i mean listen at this point i
don't even know what we're hoping for
we're hoping for a treatment we're
hoping for a vaccine
we're hoping for some common sense and
the removal of trump but it's we're
going to have some tough months ahead of
us i think it's undeniable
yeah indeed yeah and uh well i have the
opportunity i want to thank you very
much for your work especially your live
streams and everything i'm glad you're
having good success with those they're
a good informative way to keep up with
the lies that
you know trump and maggie manny and
everybody are spreading so
thank you i really appreciate that
thanks for calling in great to hear from
you
let's go next to our caller from the 402
area code caller from 402
what's your name where are you calling
from
hi david uh it's william from omaha
nebraska
william from omaha the oracle of omaha
is how we're going to put you into our
into our system okay
um yeah my question was actually about
um
about an election that's going on uh in
nebraska right now
so there's uh the democratic
primary winner for the u.s senate is uh
chris jassinek
and he's recently uh recently
screenshots have come out of him making
crude sexual jokes to his campaign staff
and uh the nebraska democrats have voted
to replace him
with uh alicia shelton but since jasmine
already won the primary he has to step
down right um there have been petitions
to call him to like end his campaign
and my question was uh do you think
there is any chance that he actually
steps down uh since he already won the
primary
because like i definitely don't want to
vote for his opponent ben fass
i have no idea now is is ben sasse
cruising to re-election regardless
um it's uh it's kind of
you know i'm i'm not sure he's the
incumbent right now yeah he's
uh he's popular
in in my area it's kind of hard to judge
from omaha i mean let me put it this way
i've not read anything about that seat
being one of the ones democrats could
take is that
fair to say it's not like ripe for the
picking for a republican to lose
well yeah but nebraska is also kind of a
toss-up state now we used to
lean republican but in the more recent
polls um
were getting more and more blue
so um if there is in my opinion if he
doesn't step down i would think
that it would be for sure that then sas
would get reelected
yeah i'm not able to find any polling i
mean listen i don't think there's any
way to force this guy to step down i
really don't know about the messages i
don't know about the race i really don't
know anything about it but
i'm not aware of any way to force him to
step down and
i guess the reason i was asking about
whether it would be close or not is
uh if if ben sasse is going to win
either way
maybe that figures into the calculation
but i really just don't know enough
about it to say
okay well uh thanks for your time david
i really appreciate it
thank you i appreciate the phone call
let's go to our caller from the 832 area
code who's calling today from 832
hi david is this me yes it is
all right uh thanks for thanks for
picking up my call and um
i know you're not a historian david but
this election to you you know
do you think it's just an unprecedented
election or do you see any similarities
between this election
you know any previous election you've
lifted war in history
so in terms of similarities i
i'm less clear what i can tell you is
it's the most important election
i will be voting in and earlier in the
week i gave this example of you know in
2012 when barack obama had been in for
four years
we were in the middle of an economic
recovery mitt romney was was running
against barack obama and
he didn't really have a great case as to
why you should even really vote for him
and he's going to lower taxes for rich
people and he had some
you know different different ideas about
the direction he wanted to take health
care and
of course socially romney was much more
conservative
but i said leading up to that election
i believe barack obama is the better
candidate and i believe barack obama has
earned a second term
but it was not the most important
election in that most likely the economy
was going to probably do well between
2012
2013 and 2017 regardless of whether it
was romney or obama
this is a very different situation where
our ability to recover from four years
of trump
is dramatically uh more plausible than
recovering from eight years of donald
trump and so
in terms of its unprecedented nature
this is without a doubt the most
important election i will be voting in
interesting interesting and i'm guessing
that in
in 2016 that at the time that was the
most important election you'd be voting
but this has superseded what's crazy is
there was a large well let me let me
back up
there was a group of people on the left
who in 2016 was saying
this doesn't feel that important i mean
you know corporate
corporate corrupt hillary versus trump
i don't care if it's not going to be
bernie it doesn't make it
look at how consequential the 2016
election was
consider how different things would be
on the virus today if it had been
hillary clinton
rather than donald trump and so i
believe that
there were a lot of people who didn't
think 2016 was that important
in retrospect we know that that was very
very wrong
interesting yeah no i agree with that i
definitely agree and
yeah with with hillary i think the
approach to the virus would have been
probably the antithesis
absolutely and it would have been not
about hillary it would have been about
doctors whereas now it's all about trump
and trump's fights with doctors and etc
if it had been hillary it would have
been much less about fireworks it would
have been we're having doctors run this
we're having doctors make decisions
because that's who should be doing it
public health officials
yeah yeah she would have been a good
administrator in the sense of delegating
tasks
yes you know yeah thanks for taking my
calling
appreciate it thank you so much for the
call we're going to take a brief break
but if you're holding don't hang up
that's my advice because
i'm going to go right back to the phones
after this short break
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
the phone lines are on fire right now
you should see the phone bill i'm about
to get let's go back to the phone lines
at 617-830-4750
let's check in with dontel from florida
last time
when dontel called in we went to dontel
and the line was dead
but i'm glad to see that dontel is back
what's going on with you
um hey so i wanted to talk about um
kind of the direction of the the lesbian
movement in the country
sure so so yeah
a lot of people on the left myself
included made the calculation a while
ago
that the best strategy to get social
democratic policies implemented
would be by uh taking over the
democratic party okay
like with groups of justice democrats
our revolution
but now that we're in a pandemic
unprecedented economic crisis
we're literally in a political reality
that no one could have ever
expected or anticipated so
and the elected progressives they failed
miserably they've got no major policy
wins
and by their own admission they don't
even plan on getting
like important policies like medicare
for all ubi
debt and rent cancellation for at least
four years
maybe even longer than that so
how effective do you think the
progressive takeover the democratic
party has been
and do you think that the majority of
the country
that was already living on the brink
before the the all of this happened
do you think that they can go another
four years without medicare parole or
ubi
or rent cancellation so i mean there's a
lot of questions in there dontel the
first thing is
did you say something about canceling
everyone's rent for four years everybody
lives rent free for four years
or are these governments subsidized okay
yeah i
i've not even heard that proposed who
proposed that
yeah that's the thing nobody's proposing
oh you want it oh i'm sorry you want
rent cancelled for four years
there by all estimates at least
20 million or 23 million people are
expected to be
evicted by october yes so
this this is as a result of the pandemic
and economic crisis
and neither of them are going anywhere
anytime soon right
so it does make sense to cancel
rent or at least have government
subsidize rent for the duration of the
crisis
okay yeah i just i guess i just i think
four years is a non-starter and i don't
think the crisis is going to last four
years i hope
four years i said they think that the
elected progressives
their plan isn't to get any medicare for
all the ubi or anything like that for at
least four years till they have some
sort of
super majority i guess oh i
misunderstood you dantel i'm sorry you
weren't proposing cancelling it for
four years you were saying there's not
going to be any proposal to do it
for the four years that joe biden would
be president i think now i understand
you right
yeah okay so listen um progressive
takeover the progressive takeover of the
democratic party
i think that a lot of this is about
managing expectations
and i know you and i dantel have had our
differences
over the you know time that you've been
calling in but
and this may be one of them my
perspective is
that the progressive takeover you would
like to see
may not be in line with what most
democratic voters actually want and what
i would point to is that
biden really won the primary not by a
little but
really by quite a bit i mean he was up 2
million votes at the point at which
bernie kind of started to
white flag and so i'm coming at it from
a different approach
which i'm obviously glad to hear how you
disagree with it but
my approach is uh joe biden
said that he would use the green new
deal as a framework for his climate plan
and he he has to a great degree and in
fact there were bernie supporters who
were mad
that he copied stuff from bernie on
climate it's like that's good i want him
copying stuff from bernie on climate
in terms of his tax plan it's a far more
progressive tax plan than what barack
obama
wanted and if it becomes a reality it
would be a significant
incremental step i mean a limiting
eliminating stepped-up basis and
capital gains you know a lot of
different things so we might have
different expectations and that's okay
i want to work together with with folks
with your perspective dantel
but i think that when we talk about a
progressive takeover
we're probably talking about two
different things and as you're defining
it
we're not going to see it under joe
biden that's for sure are we going to
see
the most progressive platform of any
president in history
if biden is elected right not if not
platforms that have been proposed
but of an actual office holder that's
what biden would be if he wins
i i know what you're saying about that
and to the first one
that you made about um the democratic
party the voters in the democratic party
aren't as
left as as myself or as i think that
they are i
i strongly disagree with that if you
look at the exit polls from basically
every state in the primary
medicare for all was in the majority
and that was even before we had a a
public health crisis like a
deadly global pandemic so i
think that it's not a matter of the
voters i think it's just
it's not working in the democratic party
that may be now done
can i just push back a little bit about
what you said so you if i i want to make
sure i understand what you said
yeah you said you see you believe that
the the democratic party actually is as
left as you believe it to be
and as evidence you said that the exit
polls showed a majority want medicare
for all did i understand you correctly
yeah okay so the polls
i've looked at do show a slight majority
of support for medicare for all in the
democratic party
when no information is given but as more
information is given about how it would
work
the support goes down to the low 40s
high 30s
so i may be looking at different data
than you
but i don't know that that's the proof
you're necessarily looking at
i'm not sure i agree with that because
the way that a lot of people frame it
like certain um posters when they ask
the question they ask it in a
they frame it in a way like oh do you
want to kick everybody in the country
off their private health insurance yeah
but i'm not talking about those polls no
i know those polls are those are push
pulls and those are not trustworthy but
there's good data like for example
there's a great powerpoint
from the kaiser family foundation which
which has nothing to do with kaiser
permanente it just happens to both be
called kaiser
um and they don't do that and they show
that as people learn more
about what medicare for all entails
support does go down to about thirty
eight thirty nine percent
okay you did and um so one month last
day um because i feel like you could
ever have enough time to
to finish this conversation sure um i
have a small youtube channel
uh it's called unapologetic and uh about
like 2600 subscribers
and so i was just wondering if you would
like to have me on the show to do like
an interview or a segment or something
that we could talk about some of these
issues in more detail well you're on the
show right now dantel you're one of our
most frequent callers you've been on so
much
yeah but i feel like it's so pressure to
try to get
every like all the points that i want to
make into a
half of a six-minute segment it's always
right
but you know everything about that when
things calm down a little right now i'm
i'm not
you know let let's explore that when
things calm down a little how about that
all right but i appreciate when we let
me call to the show
and you've taken my calls for over a
year now um
yeah so thank you all right dontel
dontel from florida
um there he is uh he speaks for himself
i don't have to say anything else about
it let's go to a caller
from the 413 area code a very special
area code
back in the original stomping grounds
of the david pakman show in western
massachusetts 413 who's this where are
you calling from
hello david i am a new viewer i've been
watching
probably for about uh six to eight
months now
okay my name is jordan jordan and where
are you calling from
i'm calling from western massachusetts
as you told a little town called ludlow
ludlow incredible uh and uh ludlow known
for
what is ludlow known for large
portuguese population
yes and uh our fantastic high school
soccer team yeah and the soccer team
that's exactly right all right uh what's
going on today and there's
if you can try to keep the phone just a
little further from your mouth just so
you don't come in so hot
yep you got it beautiful um so
my question is what do you think the
tipping point was for the sudden change
in um rhetoric from trump regarding
coronavirus
was the new campaign manager it
obviously wasn't the tulsa rally wasn't
the backlash for the fire
fauci uh retweets what do you think the
tipping point was
i think it's desperation i think at this
point so it's possible that removing
brad parscale as the manager and
bringing on that guy
bill stephen i think his name is it's
possible that stephen said
listen i will do it but you've got to
listen to me
and it what you're referring to for
people who didn't see it is earlier this
week when trump restarted the
coronavirus press briefings he did the
first one on tuesday
he came out and talked about how in
favor he is of masks trump said it may
get worse before it gets better rather
than constantly telling us that it's
about to go away
a very notable change in rhetoric i
think it's desperation i think at this
point trump sees the polling he publicly
says it's fake polling
i think he knows that it's real polling
and this is his last shot he's realizing
people start voting in six weeks the
coronavirus is going to be here for some
time
um the vaccine is not going to be widely
available before the election
and he needs to try something else what
he's done so far hasn't worked i think
he's a desperate
cornered scared man the paramilitaries
in portland are part of it
try to create some confrontations to
make uh protesters look bad maybe
that'll help
a new rhetoric it's desperation and i
don't know whose idea it was but clearly
someone got to him and said you've got
to take a new approach
i would like to think that in a more
sane world
that the scientific backlash and for
especially from the cdc
gauche and redfield yes they're actually
sticking up for fauci
and that maybe just maybe he would have
listened to that but
obviously it has everything to do with
the re-election chance
everything that's happening right now is
about re-election
and trump's gambit was reopen
reopen schools reopen businesses reopen
everything
hope that it doesn't get bad right away
so that things are okay enough in
october that people vote to re-elect
trump
clearly it's not happening clearly it's
not happening and the numbers have gone
the opposite direction so he's trying
the next thing and it is
all about getting reelected we'll see if
it works
yeah i guess like the the last example i
would
um offer up is do you think that there's
some internal
um charts or i'm sorry i'm forgetting
like the internal polling scientific
word
no not polling but um charts that are
showing
the projected death rate that is to come
in august
october september november oh
certainly and i mean listen some of
those are public and they're talking
about i think it's in the range of
you know reaching anywhere from two to
two hundred and ten to two hundred and
sixty 000 deaths
if things continue to accelerate and i'm
sure that the white house has all that
data
yeah yeah well thank you for your time
david all right appreciate the phone
call thank you very much
great to hear from you let's go next to
our caller
from the 385 area code who's calling
today from 385
hi david this is laura from somerville
math
laura in summerville laura tell me yeah
let me ask you something what's going on
with my favorite somerville cafe
diesel cafe i obviously have not been
there since the start of the pandemic
are they doing okay
i think so they're just doing a lot of
just take out
got it okay well i hope to get back
there when things normalize
yeah um so my question is about the
if you're following the primary race
here in
in massachusetts the kennedy marquee and
kind of what your
thoughts on that race are so listen i i
have
friends that are working on both
campaigns the re-election campaign for
ed markey
and the challenge campaign um
for for uh kennedy and i have to tell
you
i am very strongly leaning towards marky
it's not obvious to me that kennedy is
uh you know some progressive hero of any
kind
um he strikes me as relatively
establishment
i don't know that there's much benefit
to replacing a senior senator
with someone who would be the lowest on
the totem pole in a legislative body
like the senate where seniority matters
so much uh i believe that um the debate
was
very bad for kennedy uh and marky did
very well so i'm just not
seeing if i'm if i want to make a change
it needs to be
super clear to me that we're making a
change for the better and i'm just i'm
not at all convinced of that right now
okay yeah that's kind of where i've been
at i've lived here for 10 years and
since i moved here
i mean marky has always seemed to be on
the right side of things
from a progressive standpoint so just
curious where you were with that
so the other thing that i've not loved
about the kennedy ads is this idea that
it's his time
sort of just making an age case where
like he's younger than marky
and it's in now to replace
older democrats with younger democrats
and that
that i don't find that to be
particularly good
uh reasoning particularly when you're
talking about
again losing the seniority that ed
markey has so that i've been a little
turned off by those ads
right well and also kind of that idea of
something new when he's a kennedy
like let's not forget that part that's a
fair point as well yeah and i you know i
don't care so much about that but i
think that that's a reasonable
reasonable point as well yeah right
okay well thanks all right thank you for
the call
hope to be back up in summerville soon
appreciate it thank you
let's see if we can hear from our caller
from the 206 area code who's calling
today from 206 is that me
yes it is hello yes that's right yes
this is
the this is the misanthropic curmudgeon
from seattle
okay can you maybe just be don't quite
yell
so much into the phone and i think we're
gonna hear you fine
okay can you hear me now yes that's
better
okay i actually had a couple statements
and then a question
okay uh the first statement is that uh
thanks to trump
i think we now officially live in that
[ __ ] country between canada and
mexico
right and my other statement
is that i believe a free country should
be founded on integrity and empathy
with four fundamental foundations of no
harm
uh no take uh
no betrayal and no destruction okay
um that that being said what is our
breaking point
with this unconstitutional criminality
that
we are compelled to do something next
level to take our country back
wait wait so which unconstitutional
criminality are you referring to
well just in general with the
corporations not paying taxes
mitch mcconnell not pushing through
voter protections and
just the list is endless okay i mean i
think the answer is
the portland the portland federal age i
mean how much
more will we endure this tyranny right
before it collapses well so what do you
want to do about it tell me what you
what's your plan
well i'd like to see national
initiatives where we actually hear from
the people
yeah on what they want on a national
level instead of state by state
okay and then what kind of actions would
you like to see are you talking about
mass rallies mass call outs from work
strategic defaults what are what are you
thinking of
well my understanding of the way the
country is supposed to work is we elect
people to represent us but what has
happened in essence
is we are electing people to overlord
over us
and that's i think the fundamental
problem is we don't have a
representative government
the government does whatever it wants
and we just have to take it well we can
we can vote on someone else right we
could vote in someone else
except that once you get someone in as
in the case of trump
then he's there what he does he you know
he's duly elected this
and due process that but he's erased all
of that
with his contemptuous unconstitutional
tyrannical behavior
well we've got to remove him in three
months then right
i'm sorry to hear that we've got to
remove him in three months then for sure
yes but there's still the residual of
the mitch mcconnell's the steve mnuchin
absolutely absolutely well listen check
out my video
trumpism doesn't end when trump leaves
because that's exactly
the heart of uh of what i'm getting at
listen i appreciate the call i think
your questions that you're you're asking
some big questions they may be even too
big for me
um but i think you're thinking about a
lot of the right things thanks to
everybody who called in and as always i
apologize i'm not able to take every
phone call
we're going to take a break and we will
be back right after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your chemex or french
press or
a david pakman show t-shirt it's all
available
on our website shipping to anywhere in
the world
at davidpakman.com gear don't miss the
bumper stickers too
davidpakman.com forward slash gear
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay let's get into audience questions
for the week a lot of very
sort of similar it's clear what the
audience is thinking about and i
understand why
first question is david what do we do if
donald trump refuses to accept
election results so there's two
different ways that
accept can be interpreted he refuses to
accept them and that he claims it was
rigged but he's still leaving
or he refuses to accept it and that he's
going to try to stay
in the white house now i want to again
restate
most likely we don't have to do anything
because
donald trump if he loses in november
come january 21st
will simply not be the president he's
just not the president anymore
now for me the biggest concern is trump
rigging the election and winning that i
think that's a bigger concern than him
not accepting the results but let's play
it out
we see trump undermine democracy
he jokes about staying in power a long
time he says to chris wallace on sunday
this past sunday
he's not yet ready to commit to
accepting the results so now there are
articles being published about
what what we would we would have to do
if that was the case
and most of them say well we would have
to mobilize
listen you and i aren't removing donald
trump it's ultimately going to depend on
the systems that we have
so from a practical standpoint the most
likely scenario is trump is going to
leave
because on january 21st he would not be
president anymore if he loses the
november election
and there would be a new president and
at that point he would be trespassing in
the oval office and he would be escorted
out
but where i believe our efforts are
better spent because we ultimately can't
control that and i
i do trust that he will will be removed
if you physically
tried to stay what we can do is
it's only july so we're better off
doing what we can do to prevent vote
rigging making sure
people aren't dropped from voter rolls
and fighting that in court as
has been done expanding absentee ballot
access i just filled out my absentee
ballot application
this week and plan to vote by by mail
all of that stuff because
with all of these things and this is
going to come up again later in this
segment
prevention is cheaper than the cure if
trump tries to stay in office
i i really don't know how he gets away
with it he won't be president anymore
somebody else will be
sworn in and eventually he's going to be
removed and he's not going to be the
president
am i that naive right i mean it's like
are there people listening who really
think that that's naive that
even something like that like if biden
wins
and he shows up ready for work with his
lunchbox and everything
and trump's there and he says i'm not
leaving that that's going to be allowed
to happen
i don't believe that that's going to be
allowed to happen if you believe i'm
wrong
i want to hear what the path would be
and i understand the fear which is trump
has flouted every norm
he's you know constitutional violations
emoluments
all of this different stuff i get it i
still don't think that he is going to be
able to stay
i actually think that trump the
narcissist
if he loses and this is a big if and we
don't want to put the cart before the
horse and we've got a vote in all of
that that i've been saying
i think if trump loses his narcissism
will force him to essentially say
i didn't want it anyway to essentially
make it undesirable when when you have
an extreme narcissist
and you take away from them something
that they want
what they typically do is they say i
didn't really want it or i don't want it
anymore
or it's not worth that much anymore let
someone else have it i'll make more
money in real estate
etc so that is more likely to me if
trump loses to basically say
i'm out you know i'm better off going
back to real estate good luck with joe
biden or whatever
than trying to stay in power because
that's often how the narcissist works
now
the authoritarian narcissist may try to
stay in power
and trump certainly has no shortage of
authoritarian tendencies
but i believe if he loses he will leave
let's focus on preventing the
election from being rigged against biden
there we can do something
hey david if joe biden manages to win
florida back from trump
is it over for donald trump so
i understand why people are asking this
florida is a big prize electorally it's
29 electoral votes
and right now joe biden is leading by an
average of 6.4
in florida that's a range of anywhere
from
being tied in florida to biden plus 10
in florida
the real clear politics average in
florida right now is that biden is up by
6.4 so let's start with just the simple
mathematical case if you start with the
2016 map where trump won florida
and the only change you make is you flip
florida to biden
that is not enough for joe biden to win
the presidency biden
winning florida and otherwise the map
staying as 27 2016
would give trump 277 still you only need
270 to be president so florida alone
will not help joe biden win however
these elections rarely are completely
isolated
where everything is the same as 2016
except one state
flips if biden wins florida he probably
is going to win something else like
for example wisconsin michigan
or pennsylvania if biden wins florida
back
and wisconsin he wins if biden wins
florida back
and michigan he wins if biden wins
florida
and pennsylvania back he also wins and
even if trump holds florida so trump
keeps florida and keeps ohio biden can
still win by winning any two of the
three states wisconsin michigan
and pennsylvania now of course there's
other opportunities for joe biden as
well
arizona is very much in play for joe
biden
north carolina is close so in the
mathematical sense alone
florida only will not do it for joe
biden
my belief is that if we see joe biden
win in florida
he will certainly win some other state
that i mentioned
there's almost an exact analysis to be
made in ohio
the difference is ohio's only 18
electoral votes
whereas florida is 29 so if biden
flips ohio but not florida
he still likely needs ohio plus two
unless it's a very high population state
with more electoral votes
now in the end we've got 50 elections
we can't control anything other than our
one vote and we have to make sure to use
it so when i look at these scenarios you
know every once in a while i will look
at
270 to win.com is a great place where
you can start with the 2016 map
and say okay we start with 2016 and flip
this or flip that
there's a bunch of different scenarios
that have biden winning
there's one scenario that has a tie i
believe it's 269 269
and a bunch of scenarios that have trump
winning all i can do is vote and so
when i cast my ballot via absentee which
i've already requested in the state of
massachusetts
i will be doing it with the belief that
this state could come down to my vote it
is mathematically unlikely to be that
way but every single one of us should
say
would i vote if my vote could be the
difference maker
of course your vote could be the
difference maker meaning yes you should
vote and we all need to make sure that
we do
okay let's now go to the sort of third
piece of this pie
which is uh trump is losing in the polls
and trump is getting more desperate and
what if trump doesn't accept the results
now let's actually explore what could
happen that would give trump a win
um and there's two sides to this there's
the election tampering side
and there's the policy success side
now i'm going to be completely
transparent with you here
i think it is all but too late for trump
to do anything
on the policy side the three major
issues for voters
as as a per a new poll uh that we looked
at earlier this week the three major
issues
facing voters right now are according to
voters
coronavirus number one the economy and
unemployment number two which is very
much related to coronavirus
and george floyd police race relations
number three those three are very bad
for donald trump
economy is the best for trump although
he's now even to underwater on economy
so what can trump actually do that is
just doing stuff politically to get
support
back another stimulus which is now in
the works certainly could help
um in terms of you know a vaccine if a
vaccine is finalized and goes widespread
before november
it will have nothing to do with trump i
mean literally nothing but trump will
try to take credit for it
and maybe some people would be convinced
by that the reality is the way things
are going
best case scenario is there's some early
doses for health care workers
in the fall and it may be after the
november election anyway
not totally clear if some super
effective treatment is found
trump could try to take credit for that
uh
if through no fault of donald trump's
coronavirus
improves and the economy improves trump
can certainly try to take credit he will
claim credit and maybe it will help him
to to some degree
but i think you see the theme which is
we're barely more than three months out
and the failures have compounded and
been so outrageous that
we essentially need miracles i say you
know if trump personally cures cancer
and you know cancer is so many different
things
if trump cures all cancers between now
and november
okay but on the issues there's really a
limited window for donald trump to be
able to do anything now in terms of
dirty tricks
there's a lot um what if william barr
announces an investigation maybe into
joe biden maybe into hunter biden in
october
might not even work at this point i
don't know that people will fall for it
people may see it as once again like the
hillary clinton thing all over again
but that might help trump there are at
this point people willing to essentially
crawl over
a broken glass to vote trump out not
everybody of course
but there is a high level of motivation
i don't even know if announcing an
investigation would work
could trump engineer some kind of
backroom peace deal with somebody and
tout it as a victory
the the grand deal with china a grand
deal with north korea that's believable
or
the taliban maybe i i just don't know
you know we we talk about
domestic politics is what works and
right now people are dealing with the
virus and the economic fallout
i just don't know that it would be
enough to change opinions so to be
perfectly honest and this is why it gets
very
as i said earlier this week a desperate
trump is a dangerous trump
trump's best path to victory right now
is suppressing the vote
and trying to rig it in his favor which
is why we have to be so vigilant on that
game
we have to stop the voter roll purges we
have to stop closures
of voting places we have to prevent
these paramilitaries from
continuing to be in cities uh until
november
and being used to intimidate voters out
of voting
that's trump's best bet right now i
think he probably knows it
and that's why he's talking about vote
by mail and violence in cities because
he's essentially giving up on all these
other things that is why we have to
remain focused and prevent him from
using that
in order to win this election uh we have
a great bonus show for you today
remember that you can get the daily
audio podcast
every single day for free on
any of your favorite podcasting
platforms if you're an
itunes gal or a spotify guy
or whatever it's widely available make
sure you're getting the podcast
daily and we will see you on the bonus
show